hi I'm so we shall AC with et and today
I want to take a break from our regular
celebrity news coverage to talk a little
bit about a behind-the-scenes superstar
named Mike Beier if you don't know
Mike's name yet you probably do know
some of his famous clients most notably
Demi Lovato now as an entertainment
reporter here in Hollywood I've covered
Demi for many years and to be honest
with you there was a point in time where
it could have been so easy to just write
her off as another former child star
with troubles but here's why I'm a
hundred percent team Demi not only does
she have an incredible voice which is
not a joke people if you have not seen
her live yet you must but she overcame
addiction and some of the struggles with
Fame with such grace and today she's
using her voice to help remove the
stigma behind mental illness here's
where mike beier comes in he is the
mental health specialist that helped
Demi get sober and today Mike and Demi
are working to make mental health care
as mainstream as going to the gym I had
the opportunity to sit down with Mike at
his Hollywood home and to see his cast
centers in person and I got to tell you
what I learned was that no matter who we
are or where we come from everybody can
benefit from giving their mind and soul
a little TLC they came into my life for
a reason and ever since then we've been
able to do incredible things together
that person was Mike Baer so cast
initially was holding a broken bone in
place took it heal that was the metaphor
and now what we've been able to do is
help really empower people to be the
best version of themselves so we treat
everyone addiction psychiatric disorders
anxiety depression and at a different
program we help people who just want to
be better they want to be better in
their job they may be struggling in
their marriage and so we we help a wide
range we designed the space specifically
for doing what we do we have all these
different pockets of rooms and different
types of offices that create what we do
at cast centers obviously your most
outspoken client is Demi Lovato she's
been super supportive of everything that
you're doing how did you and Demi come
to me we met after a bad mushroom trip
she asked for help and she had called
her therapist another person both had
said call Mike they're this very large
man
showed up at my house and at this point
I've sobered up and I'm like well that
was the beginning of our journey from
her history and I'm struggling with
addictions cutting eating disorder and
then now getting to the other side of it
where it's about empowerment advocacy
how to change the world you know that is
that's what we do
what casted for me it provided a safe
place for me to come home to after work
every single day
it gave me structure it gave me
responsibility yes I already had a lot
of responsibility on my shoulders but it
was more so responsibility taking
responsibility of my actions and
learning how to be an adult this is
Claire and she is our brain technician
and you can see on the screen what we
try to do is we believe that
neurofeedback helps of attention span
sleeping just having clear thoughts how
do you decide on your approach with each
patient I understand that with Demi
specifically you at one point put on a
boxing regimen I think for everyone it's
figuring out what is the problem the
mind is trying to figure out solutions
trying to make yourself do something
that you don't enjoy doing just doesn't
work and so my job is to figure out a
strategy and you know like Debbie's
doing jiu-jitsu and she's already got a
stripe on her belt and she loves
jiu-jitsu and she loves kickboxing and I
create a plan around that because I knew
that for her that would be a passion
that would be enjoyable and make her
feel accomplished this is our group room
and what we do in here is we have about
three different groups a day about two
hours long everything from processing
group to art to trauma resilience where
there's other peers to kind of help you
be a better version of yourself
how has Demi changed for the better
since that day you first met her Demi
has done a complete 180 she's the
biggest pop star on the planet who talks
about her issues in a public way that is
a miracle
in the entertainment biz like millions
of
Americans I am living with mental
illness but I'm lucky I had the
resources and support to get treatment
at a top facility earlier this year Mike
and Demi officially went into business
together
Demi's now a co-owner of the cast
centers and she asked Mike to join her
on tour to work directly with her fans
basically what we've created on tour is
if art and personal development had a
baby and it happens an hour before the
concert which is inspirational speakers
we've had such a wide range of people
everyone from Metta World Peace spoken
Anaheim Demi actually spoke in Portland
Nick Jonas talked about self-esteem and
it's a real chance a real intimate
setting and there's no cameras allowed
so everyone has to turn off their
cameras now we've come across 8,000
people we've on social media everyone
has loved it we're figuring out what is
our next tour to be a part of you know
we've had so many people come up to us
afterwards saying like I've been hurting
myself or I haven't told my parents that
I needed help or how do I feel better
how do I get involved so there's a lot
of people out there that just want to be
a part of personal development movement
over here what we have inside of this
office we have case managers we have
nutritional counseling vocational
counseling how to love your job find any
job you happier with your body healthier
in your body do you think it's harder
for somebody who's in the entertainment
business to be sober just like a family
if you grew up in a family that has
dysfunction what mom and dad are saying
to us as kids and and what experiences
we have the same thing in a lot of ways
is with artists and their management
teams a lot of these management teams
that I've experienced are pretty
dysfunctional so I think that's more of
the struggle it's less about the actual
artists over here is our wonderful
practitioner alia and what we do here is
we actually do all different types of
breathwork
trauma work really going back to the
roots of our creations so some of the
work we even do is back to when we were
in our
mom's bellies you work with a lot of
celebrities do you feel like there's
hesitation from any of them like are any
of them still scared to be a dummy yeah
I think there's different versions of
you know for Demi that's Demi
she's a trailblazer in terms of mental
health advocacy self-improvement but I
do think people struggle a lot with what
will people think and when you're even
doing for the greater good a lot of
celebrities still get bad press but it's
gonna change things are changing things
are getting better
I want to thank Sophie and ety for
coming out to cast centers and bringing
mental health mainstream myself and Demi
lavato appreciate it so thank you very
much for taking the tour thank you so
much for watching now if you want to
learn more about Mike and Emmys mission
you can visit cast centers calm and to
keep up with all the latest celebrity
news tweet with me at Sophia Lacy and be
sure to subscribe to et on YouTube